Madame nous avons cet après-midi deux
auditions
oui il va certainement falloir que vous
coupiez votre micro madame mouton tant
que voilà nous avons donc cet après-midi
deux auditions et la première
réunie madame Sabine Duflot psychologue
clinicienne et Madame Servane mouton
neurologue
docteur Seren mouton vous avez coordonné
l'ouvrage humanité numérique les
liaisons dangereuses paru il y a un mois
rassemblant les contributions de
plusieurs experts partageant leurs
connaissances et leurs expériences de
terrain et vous insistez sur les effets
délétères potentiels des réseaux sociaux
l'impact sur le neuro-développement et
le fonctionnement cognitif de l'enfant
et de l'adolescent sur le sommeil sur la
sédentarité sur la santé psychologique
et sociale notamment madame Duflot vous
travaillez en tant que psychologue
clinicienne auprès d'enfants et de leur
famille au sein d'un centre
médico-social vous dispensez des
formations à l'usage raisonner des
écrans chez l'enfant et l'adolescent vos
conseils ont notamment pris la forme du
quatre pas pas d'écran le matin pas
pendant les repas pas dans la chambre de
pas avant de se coucher tout l'enjeu de
cette audition est de déterminer avec
vous si Tik Tok radicalise les effets
déjà connus des autres réseaux ou pas
s'il y a une spécificité propre à
l'application qui serait liée d'une part
aux produits lui-même avec un algorithme
très efficace et d'autre part à
l'utilisation intensive et à la jeunesse
des utilisateurs nous aimerions aussi
connaître vos recommandations à l'un et
à l'autre en termes d'éducation
numérique alors que les parents et les
professionnels au contact d'enfants
restent souvent démunis face au temps
croissants passés par les adolescents
sur les réseaux sociaux et en
particulier au regard du nombre
d'abonnés sur TikTok l'audition est
captée retransmise en direct sur le site
du Sénat et avant de vous laisser la
parole allumer à l'autre pour un exposé
luminaire je vais procéder au formalités
d'usage pour les commissions d'enquête
et vous rappelez donc qu'un faux
témoignage devant la commission est
passif des peines prévues aux articles
434 13 14 et 15 du code pénal et je me
dois de vous inviter à prêter serment de
dire toute la vérité incla vérité en
levant la main droite et en disant je le
jure madame
et Madame
voilà c'est bon vous avez eu ça a été
figé un petit instant je vous propose
sauf à ce qu'un ordre a été déterminé au
préalable mais on peut peut-être
commencer par vous madame Duflot et
ensuite à la mouton chacune pour votre
exposé luminaire
concerne mon travail
donc je suis psychologue pour enfants et
adolescents et thérapeutes familiales
systémiques ça veut dire que je reçois
toujours mon patient
adolescent ou enfant en le considérant
comme le résultat des interactions avec
son environnement
j'essaie de comprendre cet environnement
de le modifier éventuellement afin de
produire un changement positif chez
l'enfant ou l'adolescent
alors pour un adolescent cet
environnement hier c'était sa famille et
l'école et aujourd'hui ce sont ces
portables enfin son écran ces écrans son
portable en particulier
les chiffres d'exposition du temps
d'enfants et des ados aux écrans sont
vertigineux je donne les chiffres
américains de 2020 pour les 8-12 ans
c'est 4h44 par jour 13 14 ans 7h22 15 à
18 ans plus de 8h les chiffres français
2022 chiffres de l'étudier psos qui
cumulent les temps d'écran c'est une
étude commandée par Luna fait l'Open
pour les 7 10 ans on est à 4h42 par jour
les 11 14 ans 8h23 et les 15 17 ans
10h38 par jour ce temps énorme est dû au
fait que les enfants regardent plusieurs
écrans à la fois et qu'on va donc
additionner le temps de portable tant de
télévision etc
voilà donc c'est clairement ça qui
constitue aujourd'hui leur environnement
alors entre décembre 2020 et donc je
travaille comme psychologue dans la
fonction publique hospitalière j'ai
toujours travaillé pour la fonction
publique entre des septembre 2020 et
décembre 2022 j'ai travaillé dans une
unité d'hospitalisation à temps complet
pour adolescent accueillant des
adolations en situation de crise qui
exigeait une hospitalisation à temps
complet la durée moyenne
d'hospitalisation était trois semaines
et les ados repartaient non pas parce
qu'ils étaient guéris mais parce qu'il
faut en faire entrer un autre qui va
plus mal encore c'est ça la situation
aujourd'hui en psychiatrie en
pédopsychiatrie j'ai reçu sur cette
période environ 80 adolescents entre 80
et 100 hospitalisés avec lesquels je me
suis entretenu au minimum une heure
l'unité est prévue pour recevoir 10 ados
c'est tout à fait insuffisant elle va
s'élargir à 12 mais on trouve pas de
médecins la proportion était environ de
7 filles pour un ou deux garçons c'est
ce qu'on trouve toujours en psychiatrie
de l'adolescent il y a plus de filles
ils avaient entre 11 et 17 ans avec une
moyenne d'âge de 13 ans et demi
les motifs de l'hospitalisation ces des
troubles anxieux massifs des troubles du
comportement sous forme d'une
hétéro-agressivité mais beaucoup plus
fréquemment d'une auto-agression
c'est-à-dire des mutilations
scarification tentatives de suicide par
médicaments parfois par des fenêtres
rations j'ai observé sur cette période
une augmentation importante du flux des
hospitalisations j'ai pas de chiffres on
en a pas malheureusement au très peu en
France mais je peux citer ceux d'une
unité identique en région parisienne
Robert Debré cité dans le dernier
rapport du Haut Conseil de la famille de
l'enfance et de l'âge le nombre
d'admissions à l'hôpital Robert Debré
pour tentative de suicide donc j'ai des
adolescents a augmenté de 299% en
juillet août 2019 et mars avril 2021
depuis 2021 on compte plus de 40
admissions pour tentatives de suicide
par bitmestre à l'hôpital Robert Debré
c'est deux fois plus qu'avant 2020 et 4
fois plus que durant la période 2011
témoignage d'un autre psychiatre le
docteur Charles-Édouard Notre-Dame du
service de psychiatrie de l'enfant et de
l'adolescent du CHU de Lille depuis 2019
les chiffres ont littéralement explosé
avec plus de 126% de passages aux
urgences pour des idées suicidaires chez
les 11-17 ans et une augmentation de 30
% des tentatives de suicide les tribunes
donc avec les cris d'alerte des
psychiatres en charge de ces unités ne
cesse de se succéder depuis trois ans
voilà et en Angleterre par exemple on
observe à doublement des cas
d'automutilation chez les 9-12 ans alors
durant ces deux ans et demi trois jours
par semaine j'ai reçu dans mon bureau
des adolescentes surtout et des
adolescents et rencontrer leur famille
certains avaient des parcours de Vic
chaotique d'autres pas du tout j'ai
cherché à comprendre ce qui peut
conduire une adolescente aujourd'hui en
bonne santé physique et psychique aimant
apprendre et m'en bouger à devenir en
quelques mois une adolescente au teint
pâle à mimique amaigri ou en surpoids
restant cloitré H24 sur son portable et
plus particulièrement sur les réseaux
sociaux tik tokara color en tête à
partir de 2021
pour comprendre ce qui s'est passé pour
ces jeunes il faut noter avec précision
leur parcours jusqu'à l'avènement
précipitant l'hospitalisation c'est à
dire la scarification de trop
l'ingurgitation des doliprane etc il
faut lire les études aussi sur cet
environnement numérique qui a tout
changé et tout à l'heure donc je vous
citerai deux études principales ce qui
est intéressant c'est que les deux
convergent ce que ce que j'observe sur
le terrain et ce que les études montrent
alors à l'adolescent je pose chaque fois
les mêmes questions comment ça se passe
avec ta famille avec l'école à quel âge
as-tu acquis ton premier portable
connecté quand as-tu commencé à te
sentir mal à avoir des idées noires en
général on observe un délai de six mois
à un an
quand as-tu commencé à te scarifier s'il
y a des scarifications que fais-tu sur
ton portable et je note précisément
quelles sont les réseaux sociaux
téléchargés quels sont les séries
regardées etc et je vais aussi regarder
si j'ai le temps alors voici un portrait
robot d'une adolescente de cette unité
c'est une sorte de de
voilà ça ne s'est pas une adolescente
type c'est la synthèse de plusieurs
adolescentes qui ont un parcours de vie
simple avant je mets de côté ceux qui
ont des parcours de vie traumatiques où
là évidemment les écrans vont appuyer
sur ce qui fait déjà mal Laura a
toujours été une enfant un peu solitaire
pas trop à l'aise alors voilà Laura ma
patiente à 13 ans elle s'appelle Laura
elle est en classe de 5e dans un collège
public du secteur elle vit seule avec sa
mère et un grand frère Lucas 16 ans ses
parents sont séparés quand elle avait 9
ans qu'elle était en CM1 sa mère était
de soignante son père est chauffeur
Laura a toujours été une enfant un peu
solitaire pas trop à l'aise dans les
groupes elle ne comprend pas toujours
sont les mots qu'il faut dire les
vêtements qu'il faut porter pour être
admises sa mère et son père ont toujours
limité le temps passé devant la
télévision rien pendant la semaine deux
heures maximum les jours sans école elle
n'a pas le droit de elle n'avait pas le
droit jusqu'en 6e de naviguer seul sur
Internet elle devait se servir de
l'ordinateur familial du salon donc de
bonnes règles en CM1 elle a commencé à
se faire harceler par un groupe de
filles qu'il a traité de filles de peu
et elle avait pris le prétexte qui avait
pris le prétexte que sa mère était venue
une fois la chercher avec un nouveau
compagnon ces filles là qui l'a harcelé
discuté entre elles via les réseaux
elles avaient plutôt que les autres un
portables à qui à 9 ans en CM1 Laura en
avait peur mais une fois chez elle elle
sentait en sécurité en CM2 Laura s'est
mis à penser très fort à la sixième elle
a entendu elle entendait ce qu'on
raconte du collège aujourd'hui les
groupes les clans les exclus les sans
amis elle s'est mis à stresser elle a
dit à ses parents qu'elle voudrait un
portable elle sait que c'est l'objet qui
permet d'être admis à peu près donc elle
leur dit qu'elles vont apporter pour
pouvoir se faire appeler en sortant pour
pouvoir les appeler pardon en sortant du
collège appeler ses parents sa mère
n'est pas d'accord elle préfère attendre
peu mais son père qu'il la voit que
l'utaine lui dit ok comme ça tu pourras
m'appeler quand tu veux donc il lui
achète un portable sans l'accord de son
ex-épouse à l'entrée en 6e l'aura
découvre un monde nouveau où les filles
et les garçons sont encore plus séparés
qu'avant ou les filles forment un clan
serrées non perméable où elles vont
parler des séries qu'elle regarde sur
Netflix des influenceurs qu'elle suivent
sur les réseaux et surtout surtout de ce
que un tel a dit hier sur snap
concernant le look ou qu'à je sais pas
Manon ou le garçon avec qui elle sort en
ce moment Laura ce sent seul très seul
l'univers de ses filles n'est pas le
sien elle a acquis un portable tout
récemment elle voudrait tellement
pouvoir entrer dans leur cercle elle se
sent mal à l'aise dans son corps elle a
eu ses premières exceptées les filles
sont réglées de plus en plus tôt
aujourd'hui c'est ça on prie de on
grossit les garçons au collège sont des
remarques lourdes elles se sentent de
plus en plus mal alors elle télécharge
plusieurs réseaux toujours les mêmes on
retrouve toujours les trois mêmes snap
comme ils disent snapchat insta Tik Tok
qu'elle consulte au départ sans rien
poster et elle va découvrir
progressivement des filles qui racontent
comme elles qui elles sont différentes
qu'elle se sentent différentes des
autres alors elle ressent dans un
premier temps un très grand sur le
logement des différents des incomprises
il y en a aussi elle va s'abonner
rapidement au compte d'une fille qu'elle
trouve belle qui raconte qu'elle a été
victime de harcèlement au collège en
cinquième l'aura pour lui ressembler se
met à s'habiller en noir comme elle elle
s'achète des mitaines des bas résinoirs
avec son argent de poche elle se met à
se maquiller comme qu'il y a et qui
poste des vidéos d'elle tous les jours
et qui assument si bien sa différence la
mère de Manon est un peu surprise de
changement de look radical elle cherche
à comprendre mais Laura lui répondit
chaquement si c'est le chemin qu'elle
préfère ne rien dire
en cinquième l'aura à la rentrée a
refusé de s'inscrire à la danse alors
que ça fait 6 ans qu'elle a pratique ça
c'est un signe très important l'enfant à
la rentrée brutalement abandonne toutes
ses activités extrascolaires avec le
prétexte que la charge de voir va
augmenter et qu'elle n'aura plus le
temps de
consacrer aux activités extrascolaires
sur snapchat Instagram les filles
parlent des scarification comme une
super solution pour faire baisser le
stress sur TikTok que Laura regarde dès
qu'elle rentre du collège elle suit sur
des vidéos de filles qui montrent leur
scarification et sans vente un soir de
décembre Laura rentre du collège encore
plus mal que les fois précédentes un
garçon l'a coincé dans un coin du
collège plaqué contre le mur et lui a
touché les seins en la traitant de
Laura a ressenti un stress immense en
rentrant elle se regarde dans le miroir
le garçon a raison elle se trouve moche
elle est une vite elle prend un
cutter dans la boîte à outils et sans
taille légèrement l'avant-bras le sang
couler ça la soulage immédiatement les
filles sur les réseaux n'ont pas menti
désormais pense avoir trouvé la solution
pour moins souffrir de l'isolement et de
la détestation d'elle-même chaque fois
qu'elle se sent mal elle a recours au
cutter un jour elle coin elle crée un
compte et comme qu'il y a elle poste des
photos d'elle maquillées vêtue de noix
ou elle danse tout en exhibant ses
scarification elle reçoit aussitôt plein
de commentaires positifs des likes ça y
est enfin pour la première fois elle est
devenue quelqu'un d'intéressant jamais
elle ne s'est sentie aussi bien un soir
en faisant la lessive sa mère découvre
des tâches de sang sur les manches de
son sweat Laura garde toujours les
manches des vêtements toujours avec des
manches longues elles sont toutes comme
ça et c'est pas la première fois qu'elle
voit ce genre de tâche mais jusqu'à
présent elle n'avait pas très prêté
attention ou elle n'avait pas voulu les
voir et puis c'est difficile de pas
devenu difficile de parler avec sa fille
alors elle guette son retour du collège
elle lui parle de ce qu'elle a vu sur
les manches du sweat aussitôt Manon se
braque et elle lui dit alors sa mère lui
dit je suis ta mère je veux savoir et
Laura lui répond tu n'es pas ma mère
t'imaginatrice un terme que toutes les
filles qui parlent de leurs parents
emploient sur les réseau alors pour une
fois la mer ne se laisse pas démonter
elle elle s'empare du téléphone de sa
fille et elle lui dit tant que tu
n'auras pas montré ton buste je te le
rend pas alors Manon hurle dégage sa
mère insiste et comme Manon pardon Laura
veut récupérer son son portable et bien
alors elle enlève son t-shirt et la mère
découvre toute une série de
scarifications qui partent des
avant-bras jusqu'au jusqu'en haut elle
lui demande d'enlever son soutien-gorge
et elle découvre des scarifications plus
récentes sur les seins voilà donc ça
c'est vraiment ce que j'ai entendu
pendant un an sans arrêt sans arrêt sans
arrêt sans arrêt dans de jeunes qui ne
viennent pas forcément d'une famille
avec des complications des histoires
compliquées alors je vais répondre
ensuite aux études je vais vous donner
ensuite des études qui montrent
effectivement en quoi les réseaux
sociaux chez les jeunes filles en
particulier à l'âge des 11 11 13 ans 11
14 ans peut être un vecteur de bascule
dans un
sentiment de grand mal-être
merci Madame et puis par le biais des
questions on va pouvoir rebondir après
sur ce que vous nous avez
exposé puisqu'il y a des éléments que
vous n'auriez pas eu le temps de donner
on saisir l'occasion du
comment dire des échanges tout à l'heure
madame mouton nous vous écoutons pour
votre exposé luminaire
merci bonjour Vous m'avez présenté je
suis neurologue pour adulte mais je me
suis intéressée à la question des écrans
depuis quelques années ce qui m'a amené
en effet accordé ce livre dans lequel
nous sommes 25 à faire des mises au
point sur
différents sujets en lien avec l'usage
des écrans sur le plan de la santé sur
le plan de l'environnement sociétal
également
et
les questions permettront de développer
certaines choses mais c'est vrai que
c'est difficile pour moi
d'individualiser
totalement les
usages des réseaux sociaux et mon
tip-top parce que l'usage des écrans
comme la souligner madame Duflot est
quelque chose de plus vaste que celui
qui est uniquement lié à celui des
réseaux sociaux et on peut peut-être
distinguer d'une part les contenus que
des enfants les ados vont trouver sur
les écrans et puis l'outil numérique en
lui-même
disons sur le côté outil numérique en
lui-même peut-être on développera après
mais il a tout ce qui a trait à la
sédentarité et au risque
cardiovasculaire
métabolique autour du sommeil d'être
chronique de sommeil ou altération de la
qualité du sommeil et des
rétentissements multiples sur la santé
et sur le problème des contenus voilà on
entend sur les réseaux sociaux et les
contenus sur les réseaux sociaux sont
extrêmement variés vous essayez d'en
parler un petit peu
alors on peut souligner un effort de
régulation mais qui n'est pas très
efficace puisque
Tik Tok comme tout la plupart des
réseaux sociaux sur aujourd'hui interdit
au moins de 13 ans mais j'ai trouvé
quelques chiffres en France ou 87% des
11-12 ans sont sur TikTok et pour eux
c'est les premiers réseaux sociaux après
Youtube qui est en train de devenir un
réseau social fortement comment ça y
ressembler les 7 10 ans son 28% déclaré
en tout cas la barrière des 13 ans on
est clairement pas en tout cas respecter
et aux États il y avait une étude en
Angleterre que vous soulignez dans le
dans le comment vous avez envoyé ou les
trois quatre ans étaient déjà 16% et
passer du temps les 5-7 ans c'est 33%
enfin voilà c'est juste cette limite des
13 ans et
indicatif mais pas du tout respecté
après
[Musique]
il me semble que le problème de fond de
ces rythmes sociaux et leur
raison d'être aujourd'hui parce que leur
raison d'être c'est d'être des
plateformes qui ramènent de l'argent à
leur gérant et à leur fondateurs ça n'a
absolument aucune préoccupation du
bien-être et de la santé de des usagers
et à partir du moment où c'est écrit
tout est permis quasiment au détriment
justement de la santé y compris des
mineurs qui sont majoritairement sur
TikTok
et c'est 85 % des usagers ont moins de
34 ans et
les moins de 19 ans doivent être à peu
près
représentés 30-40% des chiffres un peu
compliqué à l'estimer de façon fiable et
donc ces réseaux sociaux ont pour but de
maintenir l'usager le plus longtemps
possible et de le faire venir le plus
souvent possible et tous les moyens sont
bons il y a des Tik Tok n'a pas été
étudié de façon
individuelle donc on peut
on peut extrapoler par rapport à ce qui
est connu sur des autres réseaux sociaux
il y a d'une part
en fait ces algorithmes qui vont
renvoyer à l'usager un espèce de moi
virtuel un minimum qui va lui présenter
des vidéos qui seront ajustées à ce
qu'il a consulté précédemment ce qui
peut assez rapidement parce que c'est un
algorithme qu'on était très très
puissant sur
Tik Tok ou
la création d'une bulle de filtre je
sais pas vous connaissez mais en tout
cas de
d'un
prisme très focalisé sur certains sur
certains sujets va être rapidement
atteint donc une gamine qui va regarder
des scarifications va se retrouver
confronter à plein de vidéos à des
scarification si c'est autour de l'image
corporelle anorexie ou pas dire sur quoi
enfin elle va aussi être confronté à des
vidéos de ce qu'on proposait toujours
sur les mêmes thématiques ça peut
vraiment l'enfermer dans quelque chose
qui peut être morbide et conduire à ce
que Madame il faut décrivait
précédemment après il y a les trucs qui
sont qu'on trouve sur plein de sites et
qui sont le défilement infini qui nous
fait rester plus longtemps il a ce
système des likes qui aussi simple de
récompense et puis il y a tout ce
business incroyable c'est un Tik Tok
avec énormément
explosé en termes de bénéfices et
d'usagers au cours de 5 années
simplement d'existence mais vous savez
qu'on peut acheter des des
gratifications en ligne c'est des inap
achat
donc on va acheter des likes des quatre
plaques des trucs comme ça qui me sont
rien c'est juste on dépense des sous en
ligne pour avoir c'est pour pouvoir
gratifier d'autres usagers de ces
petites
smileys
et puis c'est devenu une source de
c'est un c'est un vrai commerce les
influenceurs vont passer des contrats
avec des marques à partir du moment où
ils sont repérés parce qu'ils ont un
certain nombre de followers donc c'est
en général plus de 1000 alors ils vont
être rapprochés et à tout âge ils vont
pouvoir être rapprochés pour pour être
les ambassadeurs des marques et puis
ensuite certains vont faire un business
sur sur leur page TikTok pour vendre ou
c'est pareil sur Instagram c'est pas ça
c'est pour le coup c'est pas très
différent et qui vont vendre leurs
produits dérivés ou faire la police
certains produits mais il faut le faire
de façon subtile pour que ce qu'il
regarde et pas l'impression que ce soit
uniquement du commerce que ce soit aussi
quelque chose de ludique mais ça va des
il y a des sites internet qui vous
expliquent comment on peut être on peut
se faire des sous sur Tik Tok et comment
bien faire les choses etc
et le côté un petit peu peut-être qui
peut-être très efficace c'est que les
vidéos vous savez sont très brèves elles
font de 15 secondes à 60 secondes donc
il y a un rythme extrêmement
intense de vidéos qui peuvent
s'enchaîner sans regarder très vite avec
des sujets
multiples mais une stimulation
permanente non mais en tout cas une
simulation répétée très intense et comme
le cerveau est à vide de nouveautés
c'est quelque chose qui est très très
agréable pour lui et ben cette
succession nouvelle vidéo peut être
vraiment très efficace pour capter pour
capter l'attention
donc ça c'est les trucs un peu
spécifiques de Tik Tok et puis après de
façon assez globale sur les réseaux
sociaux ça va aussi s'appuyer sur le
besoin que
nous avons tous d'être en bien avec avec
les autres de de
se sentir faisant partie d'un groupe de
voilà d'avoir un réseau actif des
échanges d'avoir une sécurité affective
même si elle passe par le virtuel après
il y a d'autres théories qui se base
plutôt sur le côté autodétermination
quel rôle on va avoir et comment on va
se percevoir par rapport au groupe et
puis l'influence sociale qu'on peut
avoir sur les autres c'est valorisant de
voir qu'on peut avoir autant de gens qui
nous suivent qui apprécient nos vidéos
etc donc c'est quelque chose qui va
appuyer sur des choses dans l'être
humain a besoin en fait et puis aussi
l'autre côté c'est pas ce dont on a
besoin mais on voit à quel point l'effet
groupe peut avoir une influence sur
l'individu
cette malheureuse
communauté de jeunes filles qui se
scarifient de communauté de gens qui
sont anorexiques des choses où on se
sent faire partie d'un groupe et voilà
qui rassurant et qui nous donne
du sens qui donne du sens et un certain
bien-être peut avoir des effets
totalement morbides et délétères si ils
sont du côté pathologique des
comportements
je pense que j'attends carrément
quasiment les limites je pense que
peut-être après en continuera sur les
questions mais vous me dites
terminer mais si vous souhaitez qu'on
passe à l'échange on creusera par ce
biais
je voulais juste terminer comment
faire du fil
oui juste en disant que vraiment les oui
sur les contenus pardon excusez-moi
c'est que sur les contenus publicitaires
ou non publicitaires ou pas il y a tout
ce qui est c'est un autre volet pour moi
des problèmes des écrans qui est que les
enfants les ados le jeune mais on a
quand même envie de protéger des moins
de 18 ans notre rôle d'adultes ou être
exposé à des produits qui sont des
phases pour la santé donc ça peut être
les produits alimentaires à haute teneur
en sucre gras et sel les conséquences
qu'on pourra développer après ça peut
être les cigarettes extrêmement
fréquentes sur les réseaux sociaux ça
peut être le tabac aussi ça peut être la
consommation d'alcool et là dessus et je
voudrais vous donner des études tout à
l'heure c'est on sait que c'est très
difficile en réalité de réguler la de
réguler la présence de ces produits ce
qui tentait qu'il y ait une réelle
volonté de ces
gestionnaires de plateformes
après je pense que question pour merci
merci beaucoup madame merci mesdames je
vous propose couper votre micro
peut-être
voilà je vous propose que nous passions
à l'échange et monsieur le rapporteur a
probablement une série de première
question
merci monsieur le Président merci
mesdames Madame mes chers confrères
merci de ces exposés préliminaires qui
ont
le mérite d'une très grande clarté et
une très grande prise de position sur
sur le phénomène
et qui m'amène à une première question
notamment une question
à Madame Sabine Duflot
les adolescents que vous rencontrez
souffre de troubles anxieux de troubles
dépressifs
mais le problème est de savoir
à quoi attribuer ces troubles anxieux et
dépressifs vous pensez que en partie ou
peut-être pour certains ont totalité il
s'agit de l'addiction aux réseaux
sociaux ou de l'effet des réseaux
sociaux
ma première question c'est est-ce que
ces adolescents c'est une question de
méthodologie est-ce que ces adolescents
ne seraient pas aussi à votre
consultation s'il n'y avait pas de
réseaux sociaux avant les réseaux
sociaux il y avait je c'est une question
un peu longue alors je la continue
jusqu'au bout
il y a toujours eu dans les
consultations des psychologues
cliniciens des enfants
qui a les mâles des enfants qui avaient
déjà qui avaient des pathologies dû y
compris dans les familles son problème
bien entendu
alors
ma première question c'est celle là
quelle est la quelle est la
façon
dont on
dont vous pensez qu'il y a un effet
spécifique que ce soit un effet soit
entièrement spécifique des réseaux soit
qui s'ajoute à d'autres à d'autres
effets
quelle proportion
vous avez une clientèle importante et
vous avez parlé d'une centaine de
d'adolescents mais sur 15 millions
d'utilisateurs des réseaux sociaux dont
quelques millions
d'adolescents
qu'elle est à votre avis la proportion
de ces adolescents qui développent des
troubles des troubles graves
je continue ma question en vous disant
d'autres psychologues d'autres
spécialistes que nous avons auditionnés
n'ont pas ne nous comment dire je ne
sais pas si vous avez suivi les
auditions mais n'ont pas un jugement
aussi tranché que le vôtre l'une je
crois que on pourrait dire d'ailleurs
une
psychologue que nous avons auditionné la
semaine dernière
comparé les réseaux sociaux au pharmacon
grec c'est-à-dire aux médicaments qui
selon la dose peut avoir un effet
bénéfique ou plutôt contraire avoir un
effet négatif sans
omettre le fait nous disait-elle qu'il
peut y avoir un effet positif dans la
construction de l'image de souhaits etc
c'est pas la même image de soi que celle
que vous nous décrivez donc
c'est ma
première question et à l'appui de ce que
vous dites peut-être c'est la meilleure
façon de vous proposer d'y répondre vous
nous avez dit qu'il y avait des études
sur ce sujet est-ce que vous pouvez nous
nous citer les études qui disent qui
vont à l'appui de votre témoignage alors
moi j'ai parlé de jeunes qui sont passés
de deux heures à 6 7 8 heures évidemment
la période pandémie enfin covid a fait
aggraver la situation mais par
définition l'adolescence est une une
période de transition de fragilité où
tout l'enjeu c'est la construction d'un
mois social une reconnaissance par le
groupe social et qui va se faire qui se
faisait classiquement autrefois par le
fait que le jeune adhérer à des groupes
le groupe foot le je sais pas quoi le
scoutisme que vous voulez mais il allait
retrouver au sein de ces groupes il
allait fabriquer son moi social et avoir
l'approbation de ses pairs aujourd'hui
se fait plus du tout les jeunes sortent
beaucoup sort peu mais tout se passe par
les réseaux et là on est beaucoup plus
dans une une reconnaissance sur l'image
de soi que sur des valeurs on va dire
partagées
alors
les l'ensemble des troubles qui se
manifestent c'est un tout ce qu'on
retrouve ce que j'ai retrouvé sur le
terrain et ce qu'on va retrouver ensuite
sur les études c'est suivant alors je
m'interrompre juste par rapport aux
collègues que vous aviez interrogé ça me
semble très important de se demander la
personne aujourd'hui qui parle des des
enfants et des écrans est-ce qu'elle
voit tous les jours dans son cabinet des
enfants et des adolescents et de quel
âge c'est très important ça c'est la
première chose parce que moi j'en vois
voilà 54 ans je commençais à travailler
à 30 ans donc j'envoie depuis 25 ans 24
ans et la deuxième chose c'est quelle
question vous poser voyez parce que si
vous recevez un enfant un adolescent qui
va mal mais que vous lui posez pas la
question des écrans vous lui passez
comme ça alors c'est bien etc mais sans
poser notamment la question tu le
regardes à quel moment quand tu rentres
du collège et jusqu'à quelle heure et
quand tu rentres est-ce que ton parent
est là ou pas et quand tu vas dormir
est-ce que tu rentres ton portable à ton
parent à ce moment-là si vous posez pas
ces questions vous n'avez aucune idée du
temps qu'il y passe et si vous lui
demandez pas ce qu'il regarde et que
vous n'allez pas regarder ensuite ce
qu'il regarde vous ne savez pas ce qu'il
regarde et qu'elle est fait ça donc ça
c'est ça me semble très important et à
partir du moment où on pose cette
question c'est évident qu'on va retomber
sur les chiffres que j'ai donné qui sont
de 6 7 heures pour les adolescents mais
un adolescent d'aujourd'hui qui passe
six sept heures vous imaginez bien que
si il ne fait pas autre chose il a autre
chose à faire pour son cerveau se
développe voilà on en est alors ce que
j'observe sur le terrain avec les jeunes
c'est des effets d'abord sur le sommeil
ça toutes les études de recense en
particulier des ados qui vont pas
éteindre le portable quand ils vont se
coucher ce qui va se traduire par une
difficulté à s'endormir des réveils
nocturnes Nathan spécifs et qu'est-ce
que ça qu'est-ce que ça fait quand on a
été un sommeil entrecoupé et bien ça
fait des difficultés attentionnelles et
ensuite des difficultés sur les
apprentissages et une baisse du niveau
donc ça c'est une boucle pour ne pas y
revenir et vous laisser dérouler après y
compris ceux qui sont sur du quantitatif
qui sont sur des études quantitatives et
donc pas forcément qualitative comme ce
que vous nous relatez tout ce que la
psychologue cité par monsieur le
rapporteur nous a dit la semaine
dernière sans se prononcer sur le fait
de savoir bien pas bien les réseaux
sociaux pour les ados c'est le simple
arrive à la conclusion que sans même
pouvoir trancher ça d'un point de vue
quantitatif et comment dire extrapoler
on arrive à la fin la question du
sommeil et ça de toute façon sur le
sommeil pour la ligne c'est une
catastrophe et quand on commence à parce
que il y a des effets positifs à
travailler avec l'ado parce que l'ado le
reconnaît que ça va pas le la chose qui
la première chose qui reconnaisse c'est
les difficultés à dormir à s'endormir et
comme justement il y arrive pas il prend
son portable et comme il prend son
portable il a plus de mal s'endormir et
c'est un cercle vicieux et c'est la
deuxième trouble qui va reconnaître que
la dos reconnaît facilement c'est les
troubles de l'attention je suis en
classe et je comprends plus rien parce
qu'effectivement termine l'attention
pour des par des par des procédés qu'on
connaît aujourd'hui les écrans en
quelque soit leur contenu mais en
particulier ces contenus via Tik Tok ou
sur Youtube etc c'est des vidéos très
courtes qui vont capter à l'attention
réflexe la relancer en permanence et du
coup empêcher que la tension volontaire
c'est-à-dire la capacité à se focaliser
sur quelque chose qui bouge peu comme la
personne qui vous parle le professeur
qui vous parle ou le livre et bien
empêcher que ça se mette en place donc
cette attention réflexe qui est sans
arrêt relancé elle empêche la
possibilité d'une mise en place de
l'attention volontaire et sans attention
volontaire il n'y a pas d'apprentissage
possible il y a pas de mémorisation et
d'apprentissage voilà et on voit ça
l'autre chose que je vois sont des
troubles anxieux qui peuvent aller parce
que ça rend anxieux ça là il y a des
études je vais reporter dessus qui
montre qu'il y a une insatisfaction de
du sentiment de vie quoi les troubles
anxieux qui peuvent aller jusqu'à un
comportement dépressif voire suicidaire
une mauvaise image de soi parce que vous
savez que toutes ces photos ces vidéos
les les
qui sont relookés etc donc une mauvaise
image de soi qui fait que l'utilisatrice
se perçoit comme lettre au grosse remède
etc une mauvaise estime de soi ça c'est
aussi important de percevoir comme
idiote parce que effectivement le temps
très long passé ou idiot sur les réseaux
sociaux bah c'est du temps voler aux
apprentissages et beaucoup de jeunes me
disent mais attendez moi je suis en
seconde et là et ce matin j'étais parce
que à l'unité ado il y avait il y avait
des cours donnés par des enseignants
c'était un niveau 5e je comprenais rien
vraiment je suis bête je me sens bête
parce que effectivement ça rend d'une
certaine façon ça fait perdre les
capacités de concentration et puis des
risques de comportement d'automutilation
chez les plus jeunes grandes
utilisatrices alors les études et bien
il y a une étude il y a d'abord il y a
un
l'étude la plus complète à l'heure
actuelle c'est celle de John aide a I d
t dans social MEDA media un mental Earth
collaborative review qui recense toutes
les études qui existent sur les réseaux
sociaux en extrayant les principaux
résultats ces 300 pages donc je vous en
fais grâce mais il y a une étude
spécifique sur Tik Tok et paru en mai
2023 dans psychiatrie rusherch qui liste
les effets suivants cette étude examine
alors
par du principe que les applications de
vidéos courtes comme Tik Tok sont
effectivement de plus en plus populaires
et les tuiles examinent l'association
entre l'utilisation d'applications de
vidéos courtes et les facteurs
psychosociaux chez des adoles chez 1346
adolescents avec un âge moyen de 15 ans
on a identifié
199 non utilisateurs et 1147
utilisateurs parmi eux
686 utilisateurs modérés et 461 gros
utilisateurs ou utilisateurs addictifs
alors ce qu'on l'études montrent que les
utilisateurs addictifs présentent des
conditions de santé mentale plus
mauvaises que les non utilisateurs et
les utilisateurs modérés notamment des
niveaux plus élevés de dépression
d'anxiété de stress de solitude
d'anxiété sociale de problèmes
d'attention ainsi donc une satisfaction
de vie et une qualité de sommeil plus
faible les utilisateurs addictifs
étaient également confrontés à un stress
scolaire plus élevé alors ça ça revient
sans arrêt dans les pas noté à de moins
bonne performances académiques à une
victimisation par le harcèlement plus
fréquent évidemment à partir du moment
où on acquiert un portable on a deux
fois plus de chances de se faire
cyberharceler à de moins bonne relation
avec les parents à des styles parentaux
souvent plus négatifs c'est-à-dire moins
qui vont faire plus de de remarques et
moins cherché à discuter à des niveaux
d'éducation de parents plus faibles on
retrouve ça partout les utilisateurs
modérés avaient des environnements
familiaux différents de ceux des
non-utilisateurs mais on trouve aucune
différence en terme de mental ou de
performances scolaire voilà donc dans
l'ensemble ces résultats suggèrent que
les utilisateurs addictifs les gros
utilisateurs de Tik Tok connaissent une
situation plus défavorable en ce qui
concerne la santé mentale la famille et
les conditions scolaires tandis que les
non-utilisateurs ont des environnements
familiaux favorables voilà une
utilisation modérée peut voilà ne pas
être associé à une mauvaise santé
mentale ou à de mauvaises performances
scolaires donc ça concerne effectivement
les gros utilisateurs mais la question
c'est on passe pas comme ça c'est un
progressif c'est comme à partir du
moment d'un produit addictif c'est
extrêmement difficile de savoir de à
partir de quand on passe une utilisation
modérée de 1 ou 2 verbes de 20 par jour
à plus puis tout d'un coup plus etc
c'est ça que je voudrais aussi vous
faire percevoir c'est tout un ensemble
c'est à dire que la jeune fille qui se
trouve équipée en 6e là qui était un
petit peu
comment dire un petit peu avec des
difficultés à aller vers les autres à se
faire des amis mais ça peut être le
garçon aussi elle va équiper de son
réseau de son téléphone portable elle va
elle va pas tout de suite aller sur les
réseaux elle était des charges et au
début elle va être dans des utilisations
modérées et la bascule elle se fait au
fur et à mesure que l'environnement
social est ressenti comme négatif si
vous voulez stressant et là on arrive
voilà et à la faveur d'événements
évidemment comme le covid alors là on
bascule dans des dans des choses voilà
alors l'autre chose aussi l'autre
article que j'ai paru que dans une étude
très sérieuse un article est paru dans
Nature communication qui est en accès
libre à une attitude de orben et bien
qui montre qu'il y a une relation entre
l'utilisation des réseaux sociaux et la
satisfaction de vivre et qui va évoluer
au cours de la vie d'adolescence en gros
ce que l'article montre je parle le lire
c'est que il y a des périodes charnières
et que les réseaux sociaux font plus mal
à certains moments de la vie notamment
chez les adolescents et en particulier
chez les jeunes filles sur la période on
se présente pour le dire voilà
simplement donc alors que plus tard ça
pas d'incidence mais si cette période là
on voit un lien très très fort une
signification très enfin il y a
significatif entre insatisfaction de vie
et une grosse utilisation des réseaux
sociaux
et puis dernière chose je précise mais
je trouverais ça triste qu'on attend
encore les conclusions de de cette étude
pour agir je précise que depuis deux ans
un groupe de l'Agence nationale de
sécurité sanitaire de l'alimentation de
l'environnement et du travail
sur les effets des réseaux sociaux et le
pédiatre Éric OSICA qui est membre du
collectif cause que j'ai fondée
en fait partie et le rapport doit sortir
fin 2023
merci est-ce que vous pourrez est-ce que
vous avez la date de parution de nature
communication du numéro de Nature
communication
c'est tout récent je vais sur mon
téléphone portable j'ai éteint mais je
le passeport voilà je vous transférais
ensuite mais c'est vraiment le plus
récent pour poursuivre dans ce sujet je
voudrais m'adresser à Madame mouton vous
avez cité d'autres effets et notamment
les effets d'addiction non pas aux
réseaux sociaux eux-mêmes mais
l'addiction induite par un certain
nombre de de de forums de vidéos etc sur
les produits toxiques le tabac là ici
cigarette etc et vous nous avez dit
qu'il y avait des études là-dessus
est-ce que vous pouvez nous en donner
quelques précisions
je vous les transmettrai si vous voulez
j'ai une liste de biblio je sais pas si
vous voulez des articles entiers ou
juste les références mais j'en avais
recensé une quinzaine que je peux vous
envoyer par mail à l'issue d'un mot vous
pouvez nous faire une une
au début où il y a pas beaucoup d'études
qui démontrent le fonctionnement de Tik
Tok par contre en effet il a des études
qui sont qui portent sur ce réseau
social Tic-Toc il y en a des
soins spécifiquement soit inclus parmi
d'autres réseaux sociaux et l'usage
pendant des enfants les ados ils en
adultes il y en a plusieurs sens
références ou TikTok apparaît quand on
fait des recherches
sur textos que j'avais regardé c'était
parce que dont j'avais subi un peu la
trame de vos questions par rapport à la
régulation des contenus il y avait une
étude qui a regardé ce qui s'était passé
par rapport à
e-cigarette suite à l'interdiction par
le Congrès américain de ce type de
contenu sur les réseaux sociaux
identique toc donc ils ont identifié au
départ
un peu plus de fin 860 vidéos dans
lesquelles apparaissaient
le Congrès a fait cette interdiction et
ils ont regardé et donc tous les
hashtags ont été supprimés voilà ça
c'était bien mais après de regarder si
les vidéos étaient quand même toujours
visibles et 9 mois il y a 12 mois il
m'en restait 500 puis pratiquement 500
en France avec ça n'avait pas disparu la
majorité des vidéos restées en ligne et
celle qui restait en ligne en
particulier qui a des vidéos les plus
vues ou les plus commentés et leur taux
de fréquentation et de consultation
continuer à augmenter donc la tentative
de régulation en tout cas non pas
efficace et la plateforme n'a pas enlevé
toutes les vidéos qui contiennent les
cigarettes par exemple
après il y avait un autre truc par
rapport à
l'image corporelle qui était
médié par ses réseaux ou qu'ils ont
regardé avec cette image corporelle
l'alimentation et les conseils
nutritionnels ils ont
identifié dit hashtags ils ont choisi
pour chaque hashtag sans les 100 vidéos
les plus populaires ils ont essayé de
faire un espèce de portraits robot de ce
qui était présenté dans cette vidéo et
en gros 97% des vidéos étaient faites
par des ados ou jeunes femmes blanches
mince et qui médiait un message comment
dire normatif concernant le poids
ça entretient bien sûr cette
dysmorphophobie qui est quand même très
présente dans cette dans cette
population enfin c'est un âge fragile de
toute façon autour de ça donc ça va
appuyer sur quelque chose où il y a une
fragilité et pour juste je me permets
juste le pour continuer sur ce que dit
la madame Duflot les études par rapport
à l'effet sur la santé mentale de des
jeunes enfin des usagers de réseaux
sociaux sont pas transmets il y a des
qui disent que c'est que ça peut être
bien d'autres qui disent que c'est pas
bien enfin voilà tous ces effets sont
possibles
ce qui est
certain on estime après quand on parle
juste d'usage abusif pas forcément donc
excessif pas forcément des usages pas
appropriés indépendamment du contenu
juste très grosse utilisateurs qu'on dit
addictateur abusif c'est environ 5% des
usagers ça fait pas beaucoup 5%, mais
c'est comme pour les jeux vidéo 5%, 4
milliards d'usagers ça fait 200 millions
de personnes enfin c'est énorme en fait
donc voilà et on revient en plus dans
des trucs qui sont qui font mal au
ventre quand on est soignant c'est que
ces 5% d'usagers abusif ou addictifs
sont aussi les plus fragiles donc c'est
eux qui payent pour les autres c'est eux
qui vont dépenser plus de sous c'est
dans les jeux vidéo en ligne c'est pas
le sujet d'aujourd'hui mais c'est le
même problème on
[Musique]
émotionnel ou les autres les hormones le
corps qui change les relations qui se
mettent en tout est vraiment très
compliqué et
le
réseau social pour le coup laissera plus
le réseau social mais le jeu vidéo a peu
Apple même le rôle de couvercle de
cocotte-minute quoi quand on est
vraiment pas bien quand on est anxieux
quand on est stressé quand on a peur du
regard des autres quand on a peur de
comment on est perçu comment et ben un
écran c'est quand même vachement moins
confrontant que une vraie personne en
trois dimensions donc cette évasion vers
la virtualité qui donne une illusion
qu'on contrôle ces relations ses
interactions son image avec les filtres
le maquillage la peau sans boutons les
cheveux pas blancs ils sont pas ce
problème là en tout cas ils sont tous
c'est beaucoup plus c'est aseptisé quoi
donc au lieu d'être à plein dans la vie
avec toutes les difficultés que ça peut
représenter ils vont se réfugier dans un
univers virtuel dont ils ont
l'impression de recevoir une protection
mais qui va en fait leur revenir dans la
figure au moment où ils vont devoir
vraiment être en interaction peut-être
plus tard dans le monde du travail ou
dans leurs études et puis avec aussi des
choses qui leur échappent complètement
alors sur le domaine et la protection de
de leurs droits à l'image où ils vont
poster des vidéos qui vont les
poursuivre jusqu'à la fin de leur jours
ou de les s'excuses en tout cas les
vidéos elles se mettent en mettre en
scène de façon plus ou moins dénudée ou
des parties d'eux enfin et sans avoir
conscience de ce que ça va générer pour
eux et là pour le coup c'est pas que les
5% d'usage abusif c'est ils ont ils ont
tous cette fragilité là parce qu'ils
sont en une période de leur vie ou c'est
leur vie en fait l'apprentissage de la
relation et la régulation des émotions
et il y a vraiment un lien pour le coup
entre cette discrimulation émotionnelle
physiologique et puis l'usage abusif et
puis le fait de se faire
merci beaucoup
vos deux interventions m'amènent
évidemment à la à la question suivante
c'est que à partir du moment où décrivez
les effets négatifs et vous les décrivez
de façon vraiment extrêmement
importantes
comment
limiter ses effets négatifs
est-ce que vous êtes favorable des à des
solutions de régulation et lesquelles
est-ce que vous êtes favorable à des
solutions d'interdiction en de ça d'un
certain âge
est-ce que
[Musique]
est-ce que par exemple mais c'est un
exemple le permis 12 est-ce que on
devrait s'inspirer des mécanismes de
régulation prévu pour la version
chinoise de l'application c'est-à-dire
le blocage automatique du temps d'écran
au bout de 40 minutes je crois sur
TikTok
voilà est-ce que vous pensez qu'une
régulation est possible ou bien est-ce
que par exemple au dessous de 13 ans ou
sous de 15 ans il faut interdire l'usage
des réseaux sociaux en général ou TikTok
en particulier le sujet est compliqué
peut-être vous pouvez nous donner des
pistes l'une et l'autre parce que là je
sais pas à qui je pose la question
peut-être à vous deux
je pense que nos deux interventions se
complètent très bien je suis absolument
d'accord avec tout ce qu'elle a dit bon
moi je me contente pas de d'écouter les
enfants et les ados et leur famille
j'essaye aussi trouver des solutions
voilà donc
alors on a affaire un produit qui est
addictif je parle pas Tik Tok je parle
des réseaux sociaux en général et même
tout le modèle des plateformes
l'objectif c'est ce qu'on appelle
l'économie de l'attention on le sait
c'est de garder captif le plus longtemps
l'utilisateur pour
engranger le plus de bénéfices possible
donc évidemment on a à faire un produit
éminemment addictif le problème c'est
qu'il est dans les mains de mineurs
voilà et jusqu'ici on les politiques de
santé concernant les produits addictifs
ont tout montré qu'une simple
sensibilisation ne suffit pas je
reprends l'exemple de l'alcool
voilà il a fallu attendre
1956 pour que l'alcool soit interdit au
moins de 14 ans dans les cantines et
1981 pour qu'il soit supprimé pour les
lycéens aujourd'hui dans les
consultations on a très peu d'enfants
qui souffrent d'alcoolisme chronique on
en avait beaucoup plus le siècle dernier
au début du siècle c'est-à-dire que
chaque fois qu'on a un produit dangereux
dans les effets secondaires sont
dangereux pour le luminaire sensibiliser
ne suffit pas il faut protéger et
protéger ça veut dire interdire alors
concrètement moi comment je m'en sors
dans ben voilà dans mes consultations en
France ou en termes de politique de
prévention très peu rien n'est fait il y
a aucune évidemment interdiction alors
je vais dire chose simple pour des
enfants entre 0 et 10 ans
c'est assez simple j'estime que c'est
les parents qui sont maîtres du jeu
et donc c'est à eux de prendre des
décision de limiter en gros ce qui est
simple c'est rien pendant la semaine et
le week-end et les jours sans école on
limite à une heure ou deux voilà c'est
en principe assez simple évidemment on
surveille le contenu
et puis tout ça passe par la question de
l'exemplarité les enfants ne feront les
choses que si les parents eux-mêmes
évidemment
font de même bon ça c'est assez simple
ça marche assez bien quand c'est on
explique bien aux parents en quoi et
bien c'est délétère pour le
développement de l'enfant de passer du
temps trop de temps sur les écrans et
comme généralement les parents veulent
le meilleur pour leur enfant ils
comprennent et ils mettent en place les
règles et ces fameux quatre passes sont
assez utiles ensuite vient la question
de l'école de l'entrée en 6e alors là le
problème c'est pas les parents c'est pas
l'enfant c'est l'école c'est l'éducation
nationale c'est le collège parce que à
partir de la sixième évidemment l'enfant
il a je vous expliquais il a travaillé
au corps ses parents des les vacances
d'été pour avoir son portable qui est
l'objet d'introduction
mais même s'il en a pas même si les
parents ont tenu bon en lui disant bah
attends non pas avant la seconde la
quatrième moi je suis au courant machin
etc et bien il va avoir à se trouver
face à des enseignants qui lui disent
les devoirs on les prend pas pas la
peine quand vous rentrez quand tu
rentres à l'école tu te branches sur
Pronote mon cartable.fr etc et tu vas
regarder les devoirs c'est là que sont
tes devoirs et puis aussi n'oublie pas
il y a un devoir à faire ensemble donc
ben oui par WhatsApp insta vous faites
vous faites ensemble l'exposé parce que
maintenant les exposés ça se fait plus
en allant chez le copain même si il
habite dans le même immeuble on fait ça
etc donc tout est fait pour lui dire d'y
retourner et quand l'enfant il ouvre
l'ordinateur même celui le petit qui a
pas de de portable son ordinateur qu'il
a eu personnel de travail ben quand à
gauche il y a Pronote et à droite il y a
fortnite où il y a le réseau social etc
au niveau du cerveau il n'y a pas de
choix possible il y a pas d'arbitrage
c'est pas l'un ou l'autre c'est que ça
qui voit c'est-à-dire c'est que le
réseau social ou que le jeu vidéo il n'y
a pas de possibilité de choix et c'est
comme ça que sous prétexte de faire ses
devoirs c'est le parent ensuite ok il a
cédé l'enfant n'a pas de portable mais
il a un ordinateur portable enfin il a
pas de téléphone portable il rentre il
voit l'enfant qui branché il ouvre
vaguement la porte ah j'ai besoin de mon
travail à faire on travaille scolaire et
et c'est l'argument imparable et là
c'est là qu'on voit effectivement le
temps a augmenté et les parents
dépossédés de leur rôle éducatif donc
oui l'éducation nationale et d'une
certaine façon complice à mon sens de
ces augmentations exponentielles de
temps parce que c'est l'argument aussi
que renvoient les parents les écouter
c'est joli moi j'ai bien compris même du
flow ce que vous me dites j'ai essayé
d'imiter mais alors l'argument
j'ai mes devoirs à faire en groupe etc
et moi je suis maman de trois enfants de
trois grands enfants maintenant je l'ai
vécu personnellement donc je le connais
voilà
voilà ce que j'avais à dire sur cette
question
oui
je rejoins madame Duflot sur le fait que
éduquer ne suffit pas clairement alors
il y a des études aussi il faut faire
passer notamment sur les usages abusifs
des réseaux sociaux qui montrent
l'éducation ne suffit pas et que ce sont
du radical d'interdiction en fonction
des mesures parentales qui vont enlever
le téléphone qui qui fonctionnent pour
faire décrocher ça sera pas en
expliquant pourquoi c'est bien en tout
cas
et je me retrouve dans la même posture
entre
on fait souvent le parallèle et on dit
qu'on est exagère mais environ autour de
moi mais je pense pas qu'on exagère en
comparant les réseaux sociaux et autres
plateformes des jeux vidéos
à des produits addictifs ou addictifs
like on peut pas parler d'addiction
autrement pour les jeux vidéo mais bon
on va dire addictif live avec des
conséquences néfastes sur la santé alors
que l'écosociale peut-être discutée mais
pour un pourcentage de la population
fragile certains exposition aux produits
inappropriées exagécessifs ou de toute
façon abusif à partir de 1h30 par jour
pour les ados la sédentarité c'est pas
bon à partir de une demi-heure une heure
par jour pour les moins 6-7 ans c'est
pas bon pour le nouveau développement
entre 7 et 11 12 c'est pareil c'est une
heure une heure et demie donc ils sont
tous au-delà de leur de détente
d'exposition c'est pas bon pour le
sommeil c'est pas bon pour la maladie
vasculaire métabolique c'est pas bon
pour la vision il y a une épidémie
myopie et ses activités sur écran et les
activités à l'intérieur parce que c'est
pas uniquement l'écran c'est le fait
d'être à l'intérieur dans un éclairage
artificiel un épidémie myopie mondiale
la France n'est pas épargnée il y a des
effets délétères sur la rétine à long
terme on n'a pas les on n'a pas beaucoup
de recul encore on en a pas suffisamment
mais faut-il attendre d'avoir pour des
préserver donc ça doit tous ces effets
aussi juste liés à l'écran et à cet
outil qui sont qui sont pas bons donc on
doit protéger pour moi les mineurs donc
les mineurs alors ça qui a une loi en
train d'être disputée là qui est passé
au Sénat très peu de temps sur la
majorité numérique à 15 ans c'est
certainement
un gros effort et sa témoigne pour moi
de la préoccupation croissante par
rapport à ces réseaux mais un mineur
jusqu'à ma connaissance c'est 18 ans en
France donc inspecteur un mineur est
protégé d'exposition à la pornographie
partout d'ailleurs mais pas sur les
écrans c'est interdit sur la voie
publique mais sur les écrans écliques
les plus de 18 ans et il y a accès
la publicité pour les produits
agroalimentaires mauvais pour la santé
il y a un tel lobbying que c'est
compliqué des indispenser sur la télé
aussi ils sont confrontés mais sur les
écrans c'est c'est du direct c'est
permanent c'est personnalisé c'est tout
est décuplé en fait par cette cette
analyse des données de navigation donc
c'est tout ce qu'on fait j'ai
l'impression voilà faudra un peu les
trucs en condensé c'est que c'est toutes
les problèmes qu'on avait liés à
la société de consommation en général et
aux produits de consommation qui peuvent
nous être proposés et tout est décuplé
tous les risques sont décuplé
l'exposition ajustée à ce dont on a
besoin d'envie extrêmement personnalisé
donc ce sera plus efficace tout est
publicités les usages des écrans qui
étaient déjà un peu importants sont
décuplés parce qu'il est partout dans la
poche il est transportable donc en fait
tout est
beaucoup plus grand donc un truc ma vie
puisque avant quand il y avait des
ordinateurs dans la pièce commune ça
posait souci mais c'était pas
si simple d'aller sur un écran quand il
regardait des trucs pendant des heures
quand il parents qui passait trois fois
derrière généralement à la quatrième il
demandait d'arrêter parce que parce que
voilà on était dans la pièce commune et
puis ça se voyait maintenant dans une
chambre avec un téléphone portable ou
même dans une chambre n'importe où on y
a accès partout donc ça peut c'est à la
limite de la provoc mais en même temps
je crois un peu parce que je dis que
tant qu'on est pas capable de réguler
les usages des industriels quant à la
captation de la tension et à la
délivrance de produits qui sont pas bons
pour la santé voilà tout ce qu'on a dit
bah les moins de 18 ans devrait pas en
avoir smartphone je me fais pas des
copains dans
ce serait peut-être quelque chose qui
ferait vraiment prendre conscience que
c'est pas des outils anodins en tout cas
et puis en effet il y a ce gros problème
de la numérisation de l'enseignement qui
est totalement schizophrène alors c'est
pas le bon terme mais c'est quoi
schizophrène on dit aux parents et aux
enfants Attention pas trop d'écran et en
même temps on leur donne des tablettes
maintenant des la maternelle avec tous
les effets qu'on explique et à un moment
où ils sont en train d'engranger des
habitudes en leur mais bien le message
que l'habitude et la normale c'est
d'utiliser son écran pour tout dans la
vie y compris à l'école et avec la
tentation d'aller vers le récréatif
parce que c'est impossible de résister
c'est pas possible tout est fait pour
qu'il ne puisse pas résister à
ces jeux assez réseaux sociaux à ses
applications donc comment peuvent-ils
faire on a du mal nous déjà à se
restreindre d'aller regarder 15000 fois
par jour s'il y a pas une notification
en plus qui est arrivé à notre insu donc
eux donc cortex préfrontal n'est pas mûr
ou encore fait c'est mal à le faire et
en plus en les exposant à ça on fait en
sorte qu'ils n'apprenne pas à se
contrôler correctement ils seront encore
plus en peine de le faire quand ils
seront adultes
de vous deux messieurs mais il y a peu
plus le bonhomme du faux mais on n'est
pas grandi dans cet environnement là
donc on est cerveau à mûri dans un
environnement où ces écrans n'étaient
pas omniprésents et on a déjà du mal à
résister mais on le fait parce qu'on a
connu autre chose eux qui ne connaîtront
rien d'autre je suis vraiment inquiète
en fait parce que de ce qu'ils vont
vivre et de ce qu'ils vont faire en fait
de ces outils et du monde qui nous
entourent au moment où il y a des têtes
crises
écosystémiques écologique et puis ça
aussi après c'est pas le sujet
mais le côté impact écologique et
faramineux en fait on peut pas continuer
à développer cette technologie sans
réfléchir c'est vraiment faire mieux
c'est le côté impact environnemental
direct et puis c'est tout ce que ça
encourage dans nos tendances
consuméristes faut vraiment qu'on
réfléchisse à comment on veut utiliser
cet outil de façon intéressante il est
intéressant ce côté mais pas n'importe
comment il y a n'importe quel prix juste
parce que c'est la technique et qu'il
faut pas être en retard sur les voisins
que la France soit pionnière dans le
numérique vraiment
je coupe au micro je vous promets merci
Madame j'aurais bien quelques questions
mais on verra tout à l'heure
merci monsieur le Président merci
mesdames déjà pour l'exposé que les
réponses que vous avez pu donner aux
questions du rapporteur
moi je vous rejoins tout à fait puisque
finalement les réseaux sociaux les
plateformes c'est la seule drogue
gratuite disponible H24 partout
consultable donc évidemment je veux
rejoindre sur les réponses que vous avez
pu donner puisque le Sénat et vous avez
dû le voir passer à fait un travail avec
la délégation droit des femmes sur
pendant six mois des dizaines d'heures
d'audition sur
Porno l'enfer du décor alors il y a
quand même des choses qui qui qu'on doit
pouvoir faire on parle d'éducation on
parle de mineur il y a des cours
d'éducation à la sexualité ils ne sont
pas dispensés donc bien entendu il faut
que la loi elle s'applique c'est aussi
la même chose pour l'accès des mineurs
vous venez d'y faire référence et c'est
pour ça que je le fais sur l'accès au
film porno il suffit de cliquer j'ai 18
ans donc là la loi n'est pas appliquée
nous nous devons de trouver tous les
moyens oui il y a un projet de loi
numérique qui est en cours oui il va
falloir tenter de trouver des solutions
les solutions elles devront évoluer
elles seront peut-être pas parfaites
mais aujourd'hui on doit tout faire pour
mettre en oeuvre des solutions pour
tenter
d'arrêter cet accès alors il y a
question d'éducation il est question de
formation puisque là aujourd'hui nous
avons deux de praticiens qui sont formés
à ces à ces problématiques mais est-ce
que vous estimez ce sera ma première
question est-ce que vous estimez que le
corps médical est suffisamment formé
pour analyser détecter les
problématiques dont peuvent s'ouvrir et
les problèmes de santé donc peuvent
c'est pas la seule question donc c'est
pas la seule question donc les toutes
les problématique ou les problèmes de
santé que peuvent avoir les enfants
puisqu'ils bien entendu question
d'angoisse de troubles de la tension de
comportement à risque aussi la
surconsommation d'images pornographiques
le démontre et puis aussi vous avez
parlé d'estime de soi mais aussi la
capacité d'avoir de l'empathie vis-à-vis
des autres puisque avec ces réseaux
sociaux et bien la relation humaine perd
de sa on va dire perte de sa valeur et
même père de père en quantité il y en a
de moins en moins donc est-ce que les
médecins les praticiens sont
suffisamment formés après on a parlé
beaucoup des conséquences de la
visualisation et de la consommation des
réseaux sociaux qui sont là comme
l'industrie de la pornographie
finalement qui avant les années 2000
était là c'était une industrie spéciale
spécialisée dans le sexe désormais ce
sont des financiers qui gèrent cette
industrie donc n'y a-t-il pas une
responsabilité
à trouver pour ces pour ces diffuseurs
d'images parce que lorsqu'on parle
d'anorexie lorsqu'on parle de
scarification lorsque on laisse des
diffuseurs tourner des vidéos en boucle
qui vont finalement pousser des jeunes
femmes des des jeunes filles des
adolescents dans des dans des situations
à risque extrême est-ce qu'il y a pas
une responsabilité à trouver et est-ce
que nous ne manquons pas de courage
finalement par rapport à des blocages
nous nous laissons des choses circuler
sur les réseaux
qui seraient inattendable
finalement dans la sphère publique
c'est-à-dire que on accepte que des
images tournent parce que c'est des ce
sont des réseaux sociaux et on acceptera
pas que ce soit diffusé dans une réunion
donc est-ce qu'il y a pas là quelque
chose à trouver également vous avez
parlé de vous avez donné quelques
chiffres des au démarrage de votre
introduction sur la consommation est-ce
qu'il il y a un lien entre l'âge de
démarrage de l'exposition aux réseaux
sociaux et la
progression fulgurante entre le 8/12 je
sais plus quels étaient les chiffres et
le 16 18 par exemple est-ce que vous
avez pu constater que
finalement
l'exposition était exponentielle
finalement en fonction de du début de
l'âge d'exposition et est-ce que les
risques étaient les mêmes c'était la
question et puis moi j'ai envie de vous
dire que
comme le disait madame à l'instant
madame mouton finalement on se dit
encore préserver un peu nous adultes
mais en fait tout ce qu'on va pouvoir
trouver comme moyen pour réguler pour
les mineurs ça sera autant de protection
pour la société tout entière c'est ça en
fait la réalité c'est à dire que
aujourd'hui on est peut-être un peu plus
résistant mais si on veut maintenir la
société comme on avec de l'empathie avec
des rapports humains avec de l'attention
et bien c'est toute la société donc la
porte d'entrée des mineurs est une
excellente porte pour faire prendre
conscience mais cette porte d'entrée
elle doit être valable pour tout le
monde parce que le réseau social il a il
a et on le sait avec l'actualité récente
et des manifestations par exemple avec
la capacité de de
fausses informations de donc le risque
il est pour tout le monde et oui nous
nous devons de protéger les mineurs et
puis peut-être un message d'espoir
madame mouton puisque sur la route en
arrivant devant des j'entendais que
désormais il y a des des
réseaux qui se créent
d'adolescents qui refusent les
téléphones les smartphones et qui
reviennent vers des téléphones à clapet
sauf que a priori ils se forment une
communauté sur Tik Tok
merci à vous
madame Duflot peut-être vous avez posé
beaucoup de questions je vais essayer
d'y répondre à son consiste un parti
avec une autre personne derrière donc
à 16h30 c'est ça ça voilà donc alors le
corps médical est-il suffisamment formé
ben non pas du tout moi ça fait 10 ans
10 ans que que j'ai alerte j'ai été
première invitée au salon des lanceurs
d'alerte j'ai écrit un livre qui parle
en 2018 donc je répète la même chose
il y a la question de la formation et il
y a la question de la conscience que
c'est
par ce point là qu'on peut atteindre des
choses très profondes c'est à dire qu'il
y a beaucoup de de médecins qui posent
la question comme ça rapidement ou de
confrères psychologue alors les écrans
ils le regard un peu trop et tout oh bah
tu sais c'est pas bien faudrait diminuer
enfin ça sert strictement à rien quoi ça
sert à rien non si on a compris l'impact
que ça pouvait avoir sur du
développement et les impacts graves
évidemment c'est plus grave pour les
tout-petits que pour les adolescents et
pour les adultes alors
si on est convaincu de ça on va poser la
question du temps la tenir et s'engager
avec le parent voir son engagement pour
limiter puis ensuite quand c'est avec la
dose c'est avec la dose qu'on discute
seul et ce qui fait qu'aujourd'hui la
dix ans après je maintiens le enfin je
suis encore là à tenir le même discours
même si c'est lassant c'est que les
résultats ils sont magiques c'est-à-dire
avec un tout petit c'est magique quand
on passe un petit par exemple qu'à 5
heures d'exposition à plus rien les
redémarrage en termes de développement
c'est formidable et puis pour un
adolescent qui aussi tient c'est dur ils
ont conscience de cette addiction et ils
veulent enfin ils font des efforts c'est
vraiment c'est vraiment beau aussi ce
qui peut se passer donc c'est parce que
il y a des effets extrêmement positifs
au sevrage que il faut effectivement
faire ça si voilà c'est pas une question
éthique c'est qu'il faut
convainc il faut former les médecins les
convaincre de poser la question et on ne
règle pas les choses en une séance il
faut deux trois il en faut pas non plus
10 mais on est face à un produit
addictif et donc tout l'enjeu c'est
d'aboutir à une diminution ou une
consommation qui correspond à ce que le
cerveau de l'enfant ou l'ado peut
supporter alors ensuite
la question c'était
il y avait une question sur les effets
la variation des effets suivant l'âge
bon bah effectivement
plus l'enfant est jeune plus les effets
vont être graves le propre d'un petit
être humain c'est que la les compétences
les plus importantes c'est à dire le
langage le langage qui permet de penser
les choses
l'attention la tension volontaire la les
relations sociales qui permettent
l'intégration dans un groupe les
capacités à se comprendre à comprendre
l'autre tout ça et bien ce ce
[Musique]
dans l'interaction à peu près continue
avec un autre et à partir du moment où
ces interactions elles sont
parasitées par la présence d'un écran
par exemple en fond en bruit de fond
dans un dans un salon l'écran allumé
comme ça dans l'endroit où l'enfant joue
ou bien par le fait que l'adulte qui en
charge de l'enfant regarde un portable
s'interrompt de manière régulière et
bien ce qu'on sait ce que les études
montrent c'est qu'on obtient des
comportements enfin des développements
profondément perturbés c'est ce qu'on
appelle aujourd'hui le rôle de la
technoférance c'est-à-dire l'inférence
des écrans dans le développement des des
enfants
et ça ça a un effet considérable par
exemple on a vu que des bébés dont les
mamans regardaient de façon régulière
leur portable dans les moments où elles
sont s'occupent de d'eux et bien vont
être des bébés plus stressés qui
explorent de façon moins moins
[Musique]
perspicacement rapide leur environnement
juste en situation expérimentale sont
des mamans qui par ailleurs comme il
vient avec leurs enfants juste pour ce
moment-là voilà alors ce qu'on sait
aussi c'est que les études ont montré
que les enfants exposés très tôt à de
longues heures d'écran alors en général
c'est les mêmes qui ont des enfants des
parents qui regardent beaucoup les
écrans et bien ses enfants là la mise en
place de la communication du langage de
de la communication verbale et non
verbale
de va être profondément retardé et
pouvant faire penser évoquer pour dans
les cas les plus graves à des signes
d'autisme alors aujourd'hui on a
suffisamment maintenant d'études qui le
disent et qui le montrent voilà c'est à
dire le cas le plus grave si vous voulez
alors après évidemment
tous ces symptômes ils vont se ces
troubles ils vont diminuer plus l'enfant
grandit plus les compétences sont là et
un enfant qui qui aurait été très
préservé des écrans et qui tout d'un
coup à 12 ans et bien on reçoit
évidemment qu'il va pas il va pas
développer un retard grave il va pas
voilà mais il peut tout aussi bien
tomber dans l'addiction ça je l'ai vu
parce que c'est laddictif voyez il peut
tout aussi facilement mais ce qui se
passe par rapport à d'autres qui sont
exposés tout petits c'est qu'il aura de
meilleures facultés de récupération
c'est-à-dire que si et bien il consiste
madame Duflot et qui comprend qu'on
arrête tout quand ça va s'arrêter il
pourra revenir à la lecture parce qu'il
aura développé par exemple tandis qu'un
enfant qui aurait été mis dès le plus
jeune âge et bien quand ça s'arrête le
problème c'est que c'est très dur parce
qu'ils savent plus ils savent rien faire
d'autre voilà c'est le problème de ces
écrans c'est que ça ne développe ni
savoir ni savoir-faire ni savoir être la
question de la relation avec les autres
voilà
et la question complémentaire la
question ah oui de la responsabilité
alors ça c'est particulier parce que du
avec Tik Tok c'est
où les réseaux sociaux c'est
incroyablement bien fait quoi c'est à
dire que l'utilisateur devient une sorte
de panneau publicitaire à lui tout seul
c'est-à-dire que on peut effectivement
réguler dans Tik Tok voilà il y a des
publicités qui arrivent comme ça mais on
pourrait l'enlever je pense que ça
changerait pas grand chose dans la
mesure où enfin voilà vous savez quel
système de ces influenceurs qui
reçoivent un peu un puison d'abonnés
plus finalement ils peuvent être payés
mais c'est à dire que on voit comment
dire ce qu'on voit c'est c'est
c'est des jeunes qui sont eux-mêmes
vecteurs si vous voulez de messages
publicitaires ils ont pas besoin d'être
payés ils se
c'est une sorte de on a l'impression que
c'est eux-mêmes des panneaux
publicitaires quoi je sais pas comment
le dire autrement il y a que ça quoi qui
est alors moi je connais pas exactement
comment se font les systèmes de
rémunération sur sur Tik Tok mais en
tout cas je pense que c'est assez
compliqué parce que il y a il y a
finalement une adhésion totale de de
l'utilisateur de celui qui poste des
vidéos à une société marchande quoi il
est finalement tout le temps en train de
vendre des produits que ça soit la la
jeune qui montre comment on se maquille
bien les yeux bon ben elle va montrer sa
palette maquillage machin enfin c'est
toujours pour vendre quelque chose quoi
donc je voilà
alors pour la formation c'est sûr que il
y a pas de formation dédiée au numérique
à ma connaissance
en tout cas dans le milieu des
neurologues dans lequel j'évolue c'est
certain
on aura une organisation à Lyon une
journée de conférence
à l'ENS qui était pour les soignants
pour les enseignants etc enfin qui était
grand public plutôt professionnel mais
voilà c'est des initiatives
locales et anarchique
mais ça rejoint en fait finalement
l'absence de formation à mon avis
pourquoi est-ce que j'ai constaté nous
avons sur tout ce qui concerne
l'environnement en médecine en tout cas
je peux parler que de la médecine je
crois qu'il y a des avancées qui ont été
faites récemment avec un petit module de
santé environnemental pour les premières
années à partir de cette dernière
rentrée mais voilà c'est ça reste très
très modeste et sur les écrans en
particulier c'est des initiatives
personnelles
après madame Duflot a répondu et pour la
dernière
dernière partie de la responsabilité
c'est enfin c'est évident qu'il y a
je sais pas à quel point le législateur
français a un pouvoir de régulation des
usages et industriels mais c'est évident
qu'on peut pas faire peser la
responsabilité de ces mauvaises usages
uniquement à l'usager parce qu'il y a
trop de
d'intérêts financiers derrière ça pour
dédouaner et innocenter les industriels
qui sont derrière ces produits ils sont
partis prenantes et ils sont ils sont
complètement coupables et ils le font de
façon délibérer volontaire et s'y
affichés on le sait quoi alors après
c'est des entreprises internationales le
plus souvent anglo-saxonnes du chinoise
pour Tik Tok mais bon les réseaux
sociaux anglo-saxons fonctionnent de la
même façon sont pas Tic-Toc je suis pas
sûr que tu vas beaucoup plus pire je
sais pas à mon avis ils sont un peu tout
ce qu'il kiffe donc je sais pas si c'est
possible de réguler mais il y a choses
que demande régulièrement les chercheurs
qui travaillent sur ces produits
addictifs ou addictif life autant
réseaux sociaux que s'export nous jeux
vidéo etc c'est qu'il y a une
transparence ces industrielle quant à
leurs quant aux algorithmes au
développement des produits parce que
quand un chercheur et je suis en lien
avec une des équipes sur les jeux vidéo
c'est plutôt sur laquelle je suis en
lien sur en Suisse ceux qui se pour les
réseaux sociaux c'est plutôt en
Allemagne
ils me disent nous quand on fait notre
travail de rétro-ingénierie pour
comprendre comment le réseau social le
jeu vidéo ou sexe porno va capter
l'attention d'usager
en fait le travail à sens inverse mais
on doit
c'est un travail de fourmi quoi il faut
vraiment remonter la filière et pour
faire ça on est assujetti à des à des
règles qui sont juste qui sont normales
qui sont en France ça s'appelle la
Commission de protection des personnes
mais il y a des gros dossiers à remplir
pour faire de la recherche qui implique
l'homme il faut avoir des agréments des
accréditations que ce soit
les droits de du cobayes humains soient
respectés etc enfin bon il y a une
structure des législative quand un
industriel veut développer un produit
addictif ou addictif like il a pas ça il
va tester a versus B dans un panel
d'usagés B est plus efficace puis on
déploie B et c'est tout donc ça va lui
prendre un temps infiniment moins long
pour développer un produit extrêmement
efficace qu'ensuite les chercheurs
institutionnels ou indépendants peu
importe vous mettre un deux trois ans à
décortiquer pour comprendre comment il
fonctionne et peut-être amené à mieux
préserver l'usager mais entre temps
l'industrie elle aura déjà développé un
autre produit etc donc en fait on court
toujours après des produits qui qui nous
échappent parce que il y a vraiment deux
poids de mesure en terme de
d'encadrement sur de la recherche
humaine finalement industrielle d'un
côté et scientifique pur de l'autre mais
avec avec les mêmes avec les mêmes
personnes impliquées c'est aussi des
neuropsychologues sont aussi des
neuroscientifiques qui travaillent pour
l'industrie donc c'est pas voilà c'est
juste la législation qui en la recherche
qui est différente donc il y a ce côté
transparence c'est certain et puis
et puis il devrait avoir en fait
faudrait tout à l'heure c'est important
vraiment que c'est juste pousser un
paroxysme mais que ça existait déjà
c'est évident que la publicité a pas
attendu 2023 pour être efficace et
vouloir vendre des produits a vraiment
pris son essor dans les années je crois
c'était la pré guerre avec les couler la
marchandise qu'on produit etc donc il y
avait déjà ça ce qu'on est passé
vraiment un cran du dessus en termes de
quantité de qualité et de finir
d'analyse de l'usager avec toutes ces
histoires de données de navigation du
coup c'est encore plus puissant et comme
il y a derrière ce temps d'écran qui est
source de tant de problèmes de santé qui
vont nous revenir dans la figure dans
quelques dizaines d'années avec des
maladies cardiovasculaires métaboliques
et puis elle est trop visuelle etc ça va
nous revenir on va forcément le voir
venir parce que c'est déjà en gestation
là maintenant comme il y a tout ça
derrière on devrait être
tous debout avec des en Sar faut éviter
que ça arrive en empêchant que que cette
économie de l'attention se déploie avec
autant de facilité dans nos
civilisations en fait ça part en fait
c'est mon petit mon petit loyer mais
vraiment ce bouquin il est je sais pas
si vous aurez l'occasion de le lire si
vous pourrez prendre le temps de le dire
si vous êtes super occupé mais il est
vraiment venu de ses lectures que j'ai
faite sur tous ces plans santé
environnement et société un petit peu
moins c'est plus laissé parler les
autres mais on a le fils c'est pas
possible que ce soit c'est pas la
réalité tout ce que je dis c'est pas
c'est pas vrai
je viens complotiste en plus c'était pas
prête on avait perdu covid mais ça y est
j'ai basculé paranoïa complotiste ça va
pas c'est pas possible que ce soit aussi
énorme et qu'on laisse nos enfants nos
ados les adultes jeunes et qu'on nous on
agisse comme ça et puis finalement vu la
montagne de littérature sur le sujet vu
toutes les discussions que j'ai pu avoir
avec son étrange qui sont dans aucun
c'est des c'est des professeurs émérite
de trucs de machin des qui font qui
interviennent auprès de la Commission
européenne sur les perturbateurs
endocriniens qui sont ah bon bref c'est
des experts quoi et que finalement on
avait tous la même analyse et ben non en
fait c'est vrai alors on fait quoi
aujourd'hui de croire dans notre système
dans vraiment on aura beau avoir le
pouvoir de changer ça et j'espère
vraiment
je suis heureuse de participer à cette à
cette audition mais avec vraiment
l'espoir que vous ayez ce pouvoir de
changer les choses on est responsable de
ça et si on a le moyen d'agir c'est des
chaque fois je lui petite phrase qu'on
le parle avec les copains alors je vais
vous la dire aussi si je suis impression
vraiment que c'est David contre David
contre Goliath avec cette industrie du
numérique mais c'est David qui a gagné à
la fin donc j'ai tout espoir que ça
aboutisse dans le bon sens
monsieur le rapporteur a une autre
question je crois
oui une question plus
de nature sociale que médical ou
psychologique
il me semble que vous avez fait allusion
tout à l'heure madame Duflot est-ce que
l'usage des réseaux sociaux tuto en
particulier et n'est pas de nature à
creuser les inégalités notamment du
point de vue les résultats scolaires
entre des enfants de famille souvent de
catégories socioprofessionnelles plus
plus élevé qui
régule davantage l'usage des réseaux
sociaux et des catégories socio-nelles
moins
comment dire moins
privilégié
est-ce que vous avez il me semblait que
vous en aviez que vous avez fait
allusion tout à l'heure ce que vous
pouvez nous en dire deux mots alors les
toutes les études montrent
qu'effectivement
ça concerne pas simplement les réseaux
sociaux mais l'exposition
alors les USD en général et en
particulier je peux citer une étude
française et la dernière étude elfe qui
montre que d'une façon générale
l'exposition précoce aux écrans qui va
de pairs souvent avec un usage un temps
excessif d'exposition et une exposition
à des contenus inadaptés pour l'âge
touche plus fréquemment les familles ou
la mer est jeune les parents ont un
faible niveau d'instruction les familles
monoparentales c'est-à-dire un seul
parent élève les enfants et les familles
ici de l'immigration donc ça c'est vrai
pour l'étude française c'est vrai aussi
pour les autres études
voilà donc c'est je pense que dans ces
foyers la connaissance est transmise
essentiellement
m'ont par les réseaux sociaux avant
c'était la télé par des médias
audiovisuels et bien davantage que par
le livre
et puis je pense aussi que les familles
favorisées ont
probablement une attitude plus active
dans la recherche d'informations à se
contente pas d'un seul canal
d'information et elles font davantage
confiance aussi à leurs compétences
parentales c'est comme ça que je dois
faire et c'est pas les autres qui vont
me dicter ce que je dois faire ou
l'École etc voilà ça c'est vraiment une
différence que je vois entre famille
favoriser et défavorisée et d'ailleurs
dans
après dans
concernant ces taux d'exposition parfois
il y a même pas besoin de de d'un
questionnaire moi j'ai beaucoup de liens
avec des enseignants de classe dans les
classes les enseignants ben repère très
rapidement les enfants coin usage
important des écrans et se Compass
simplement en voyant leur mine enfin
leur voilà mais ce que je voudrais dire
c'est que c'est vrai qu'il y a une
différence entre souvent entre
consommation dans les familles moins
favorisées socialement ou moins diplômés
les familles plus favorisées mais ce
qu'il faut aussi savoir c'est que ces
familles là une fois qu'elles ont
l'information la bonne information
claires et bien elle prône les bonnes
mesures et moi ce que j'entends ce que
j'ai beaucoup entendu c'est OK madame
Duflot mais pourquoi on nous l'a pas dit
avant tout ce que vous me dites
concernant les effets sur mon enfant la
petite et en maternelle et qui tient pas
en place etc pourquoi on me l'a pas dit
bah voilà il fallait le dire et une fois
qu'elles ont l'information et bien elles
enlèvent effectivement elle s'instraigne
aussi à une certaine discipline et comme
ça des effets positifs sur les enfants
bah ça ça perdure voilà donc
voilà ce que j'avais à dire et
voilà
madame mouton avez-vous quelque chose à
ajouter
je saisis l'occasion mais ça va un peu
dans le sens de ce que disait sur le
rapporteur vous avez évoqué tout à
l'heure l'une et l'autre mais madame
mouton notamment le fait que le cerveau
émet la nouveauté
vous avez évoqué madame Duflot le fait
qu'il n'y avait pas d'arbitrage possible
pour l'enfant quand l'écran s'ouvre et
que d'un côté il y a Pronote et de
l'autre et de l'autre chose qui peut lui
attirer l'attention j'ouvre une
parenthèse sur la question de Pronote
vous avez même eu parce que
développement pendant le covid et
ensuite les choses sont restées
semble-t-il faute d'instruction claire
aux enseignants en fait les enseignants
appliquent en principe les instructions
du ministre donc faute d'instruction
claire on a les uns les autres comme
retour de parents ou dans nos familles
des élèves pour qui le cahier de texte
n'existe même plus on prend la photo au
tableau des instructions et on se le
passe sur le groupe Instagram de la
classe il existe des élèves qui n'ont
pas Instagram et qui sont obligés de
s'abonner à Instagram pour pouvoir
suivre dans certains cours et ça dépend
totalement d'un enseignant à l'autre il
y en a qui ne le pratique pas du tout
donc il y a une ah oui oui mais c'est du
vécu
c'est du vécu et donc il y a il y a un
manque de d'instruction au sens de
directive de de ce point de vue là alors
ma question est la suivante il y a des
personnes qui ont une addiction il y a
des jeunes qui ont une addiction morbide
par exemple sur les questions
alimentaires et pour autant les barres
chocolatées sont en vente libre et ça ne
pose pas de problème à
la comment dire à la grande majorité de
la de la population
donc ce que je veux dire c'est est-ce
que il n'y a pas deux choses d'une part
où est-ce que vous placeriez la
nécessité de comprendre là je reviens ce
que disait madame mouton sur le cerveau
qui demande de la nouveauté à quel
moment on apprend aux parents et à quel
moment on apprend aux élèves comment
fonctionne leur cerveau quand je parlais
des barres chocolatées c'est que par
exemple quand j'étais à l'école primaire
on nous apprenait les glucides les
lipides ce qu'il faut ce qui les
convient de faire de pas faire et
comment fonctionne l'estomac comment
comment on ingère tout ça nos parents
mes parents n'avaient pas ça à l'école
aujourd'hui
il y a Sam il y a toujours pas sur le
fait de savoir comment fonctionne le
cerveau alors que c'est l'organe en
principe
qu'utilise les enseignants et les élèves
du matin au soir il y a encore ce qu'on
appelle de d'extrêmement diffuser des
neuromites voilà on croit encore que en
lisant la leçon avant de se coucher on
va mieux la prendre les études sont
claires là-dessus non ça ne change pas
les choses ça ne mange pas de pain mais
ça ne change pas les choses vous parliez
vous-même madame Duflot du fait que les
parents quand on leur dit ils sont bien
content de l'avoir appris que tout le
monde n'est pas au même niveau à quel
moment par quel biais et dans quel cadre
est-ce qu'on fait cette éducation à la
parentalité alors ne serait-ce que
numérique mais de manière plus large
visiblement il n'est jamais trop tard
pour le faire mais quel est le moment
idoine et Madame mouton sur la façon de
fonctionner du cerveau
quel est votre opinion là-dessus est-ce
qu'il y a une utilité à décortiquer ça
et à quel moment l'apprend aux gens s'il
y a une utilité
peut-être peut-être madame mouton
d'abord ce que j'avais terminé par le
film Duflot après
j'ai pas connaissance du programme
scolaire donc je sais pas à quel moment
on parle du système nerveux si je veux
de mon temps c'était plutôt au lycée
pour décortiquer les neuromites et
apprendre comment on apprend c'est
simple il y a pas d'accord que d'un
point de vue physiologique on apprenne
les glandes les machins etc certainement
mais autrement sur
voilà comment on apprend ça on apprend
pas
après c'est enfin je crois que des pays
où j'ai peut-être pas bien compris la
question la question vous me demandez
quoi est-ce qu'on apprend ou quand
est-ce qu'il faudrait apprendre est-ce
qu'il y a seulement une utilité à savoir
comment fonctionne le cerveau et ou
alors c'est quelque chose de trop
compliqué et il faut laisser ça après
tout on n'a pas non mais après tout
c'est pas utile que chacun le le sache
précisément il y a quel moment faudrait
le faire
j'ai confiance en l'humain et j'aime les
gens donc c'est le bouquin était aussi
net de cette même réflexion et de même
sentiment c'est que je me dis en effet
que si les gens savaient savaient tout
ça avait ce qu'il risque ça avait
comment ça fonctionne comment ils sont
utilisés ce que ça peut avoir comme
conséquence pour eux pour enfin etc
alors peut-être pas tous mais en tout
cas certains frais autrement je pense
que interdire sans expliquer c'est
totalement
[Musique]
non productifs il faut que les gens
puissent s'approprier les raisons pour
lesquelles on va leur dire à des crans
avant 7 ans pas de portable avant 18 ans
parce qu'aujourd'hui les industriels
sont trop incontrôlables etc enfin voilà
je pense qu'il faut expliquer pourquoi
mais
malgré tout comme ces outils s'appuient
sur le fonctionnement le fonctionnement
même de notre cerveau quelque chose qui
s'est mis en place avec des évolution
des centaines des milliers d'années il
appuie sur des choses sur lesquelles
nous ne sommes pas armés en fait pour
résister la même façon que le sucre peut
vous citer des barres chocolatées ouais
c'est presque un problème quels sont
inventifs finalement quand il peut y
avoir de têtes dégâts sur la santé mais
bon en quantité modérée ça va mais bon
voilà si on rentre dans la polémique en
effet on peut se poser la question parce
que en tout cas sur ce le sucre le sucre
et les et ça à côté addictif alors on
sait bien maintenant avec plein d'effets
pas bon aussi sur la santé et les écrans
avis de façon tellement globale en fait
c'est ça qui est un peu vertigineux
quand on les regarde parce que on
attrape une pelote en disant elle ne
redéveloppement c'est pas bon ah bah
Metz mais même sur les adultes aussi
c'est pas super à ma main aussi les
artères vont souffrir l'oeil aussi et
puis même le réseau social et bouleversé
oh bah l'éducation aussi ça c'est pas
pareil qu'ils apprennent moins bien
parce qu'ils sont fatigués que ils
arrivent plus à se concentrer en fait ça
devient ces sociétales quoi c'est
vraiment une question sociétale
même du flow je voulais juste rajouter
que le bon moment pour intervenir je
pense que c'est dans les maternités
quand les mamans sont enceintes
aujourd'hui des jeunes femmes adultes
elles ont une habitude de six sept
heures de consultation de leur portable
par jour pas pour un usage de travail le
plus souvent récréatif donc il faut
qu'elle soit informée du fait que cette
passion cette addiction qu'on l'a tous
si elles veulent que leur enfant se
développe bien elles vont devoir la
quitter chaque fois qu'elle s'occuperont
de leur enfant et un enfant pour bien se
développer a besoin d'une attention
continue de ses parents donc il faut
faire un choix c'est voilà c'est
effectivement une forme de maltraitance
pour un bébé que de s'occuper de lui
tout en regardant de manière un peu
compulsive sont voilà son téléphone
portable donc il y a rien de de jugeant
dans ce que je dis moi je suis bien
contente de voir des enfants qui sont
grands voilà de pas avoir ce mais c'est
dans les maternités qu'il faudrait agir
toutes les deux merci beaucoup du temps
que vous nous avez consacré
le temps d'attention
merci